bienvenue à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition d'europe et
d'eau présenté comme toujours au coeur
du parlement européen à bruxelles
cette semaine direction madrid en
espagne
ils étaient au moins 100 milles à
défiler dans les rues de la capitale de
toutes origines sociales de tous âges
marche organisée par podemos le parti
issu du mouvement des indignés
leur chef le voici pablo iglesias il
veut en finir avec les politiques
d'austérité en espagne et plus largement
en europe le parti espère remporter les
élections régionales au printemps
prochain
et d'abord l'actualité européenne la
bataille de la dette grecque et lancer
le nouveau premier ministre grec type
rase promet de la re négocier pas si
vite
il faudra discuter explications en
images
il a commencé sa tournée européenne par
une visite chez son voisin chypriote
accueilli avec les honneurs par le
président anastasia death dont le pays
est lui aussi passé tout près de la
faillite il y a deux ans alexis tsipras
ce cherche le soutien de ses partenaires
européens le jeune premier ministre élu
sous la bannière de syriza a promis à
son peuple de renégocier la dette
grecque un fardeau de 315 milliards
d'euros qui paralyse le pays
l'empêchent d'investir pour cette
mission de tous les dangers un homme est
en première ligne
yannis varoufakis nouveau ministre grec
des finances
il a été dépêché dans les grandes
capitales européennes à londres à paris
aux côtés de michel sapin avec un seul
et unique message mettre fin aux
politiques d'austérité
il nous faut placer le problème de
l'autre côté de la table pour trouver
des solutions à ce problème avec un
objectif en tête la prospérité pour le
citoyen européen pas la prospérité pour
le citoyen grec français et portugais
non la prospérité pour chaque citoyen
requins rendre à la grèce sa
souveraineté économique
c'est le credo du nouveau pouvoir
grecque alexis tsipras ce a promis de
mettre dehors la tre k ces hauts
fonctionnaires envoyés par bruxelles
la banque centrale européenne et le fmi
pour imposer des coupes budgétaires
drastiques au pays où un jeune sur deux
est au chômage
alors le ministre varoufakis prend les
devants ils ne demandent plus
l'effacement de l'ardoisé grecque mais
propose à ses partenaires de troquer les
prêts accordés à athènes contre des
obligations perpétuelles qui serait
indexée sur la croissance à venir
l'idée que le nouveau pouvoir grec devra
défendre jusqu'à berlin
angela merkel est pour l'instant
intraitable sur le dossier
le bras de fer autour de la dette
grecque ne fait que commencer
voyons jusqu'au mans ce qu'en pense un
député allemand andreas soit bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
vous êtes membre du parti populaire
européen débuté européens et vous venez
de la cd où le parti de d'un gala merkel
est ce que un gala merkel selon vous
alors vous n'êtes peut-être pas dans
même sûrement dans sa tête mais c'est
votre parti et ce qu'elle peut discuter
en l'état actuel des choses avec alexis
tsipras ce et sur quelle base
je pense que comme tous les autres états
européens nous avons suivi avec le plus
grand respect la décision du peuple grec
du vote dimanche dernier mais de notre
point de vue et on voit que c'est un
point de vue qui est largement partagée
aussi dans les états du sud de l'europe
c'est clair que le nouveau le nouveau
gouvernement grec peut proposer de
nouvelles choses mais sur la base des
décisions qui ont été prises dans le
passé
c'est à dire celle de c'est à dire c'est
à dire que nous sommes prêts c'est à
dire que d'après ce que j'ai lu dans les
journaux
tout le monde est prêt en europe à aider
afin d'arriver à cette prospérité pour
le citoyen européen qui n'est pas un
citoyen grec seulement mais aussi un
citoyen par exemple cypriote et le
chypre a prêté à la grèce 110 millions
dans un moment très difficile pour ce
petit pays et ce petit pays et les
citoyens là ne veulent pas perdre leur
argent et je pense c'est un fait qu'il
faut respecter aussi à vous dites que
les choses se sont retournés c'est
maintenant des pays du sud qui eux même
s'indigne finalement 2-2 qu'on
accorderait des avantages particuliers à
la grèce c'est ça non mais je sais ce
que j'observe c'est que le ministre des
finances italien
le ministre des finances français le
ministre des finances
en espagne le ministre de finances en
chypre et je pourrais ajouter d'autres
exemples disent tout on est ouverts pour
des propositions grecques
mais on n'est pas là pour laisser de
côté de l'argent que nous avons prêté à
la grèce dans un moment critique pour
nous aussi
je pensais la ligne des européennes et
on va voir ce que ça va donner la visite
du ministre du premier ministre aux
petits princes ici à bruxelles
aujourd'hui vous dites que c'est en tout
cas qui est un changement de la part de
ces pays qui était plutôt enclin à
pratiquer le relâchement budgétaire et
vous mettez la france dans ce groupe des
pays du sud
non je pense je pense qu'il faut qu'il
faut être très clair le but n'a jamais
été l'austérité c'est un peu faux dans
le dans les commentaires
le but a été d'arriver à des réformes
structurelles justement qui le dit
l'austérité c'est lui qui weeks et
messieurs le disent mais de notre point
de vue on a fait des réformes pour
arriver exactement à cette prospérité
pour tous les citoyens européenne et
malheureusement on n'a pas encore
tranché toute la guerre ne doit pas
efficace pourquoi est ce que ça ne
produit pas assez ses fruits ces
politiques d'austérité beaucoup
d'économistes le 10 et même les états
unis le doublé ça c'est un débat
difficile
de notre point de vue ces réformes
structurelles n'ont pas été menées afin
je pourrais vous donner des exemples les
un certain nombre de mesures qui ont été
présentés au début traîne depuis des
mois et ces mesures qui est peut-être
font mal au début mais très rapidement
et très représenté un exemple pour
comprendre l'exemple le plus positif je
dirais c'est que la flexibilité du droit
de travail en grèce a été finalement
achevé et on a déjà vu les premiers
effets positifs et à ce moment-là
peut-être s'était pas très bien
organisée à ce moment là le vote en
grèce est en train de retourner tout en
avant ça serait un grand problème nous
la grèce a fait un grand pas en avant et
on peut l'indiquer avec des analytiques
économique et donc je pense qu'il faut
se baser sur ces réformes là et pas les
mettre en question alors alexis tsipras
se doit persuader ses partenaires et
notamment un gala merkel on le disait
les négociations s'annoncent serrés je
vous propose d'écouter le point de vue
de cet économiste allemand on se
retrouve juste après
bigard les prochaines semaines seront
captivante
on va voir jusqu'à quel point les pays
européens sont prêts à faire des
concessions et la position allemande
sera décisive
à quel point angela merkel sera t elle
prête à changer d'orientation
tharoor dans la roseraie
est ce que le gouvernement allemand
andreas schwab peut alors peut-être pas
changer ça sa politique on l'a bien
compris fixer sur le cap unique de
l'austérité n'est ce qu'il peut y avoir
quand même une inflexion vu ce nouveau
contexte européen
je pense qu'il faut être clairement dire
il faut clairement dire que c'est pas
une position que l'allemagne est peu
changée elle même unilatéralement
c'est le roseau qui a pris des décisions
c'est l'eurozone tous les états membres
absolument c'est toute la maisonnée des
finances de tous les pays de l'eurozone
qui ont dit on veut aider à la grèce
c'est tous les pays de l'eurozone qui
ont mis de l'argent sur la table
donc c'est pas l'allemagne alors se dire
aux jeunes bien sûr volonté moulant être
constructif nous voulons arriver dans
une situation dans laquelle la grèce
plus rester facilement dans la zone euro
mais au même moment il faut aussi dire
que les réformes doivent être menées
afin en grèce
en même temps vous disiez que ce nouveau
gouvernement grec on peut lui accorder
le bénéfice du doute
le ministre de l'économie monsieur
varoufakis a des idées il propose
notamment des changes et donc les prêts
consentis à ces pays contre des
obligations perpétuelles pour vous c'est
l'idée qui peut être acceptable ça je
trouve le positif dans ce contexte qu'il
a déjà changé le langage qu'il a utilisé
juste après les élections
donc on voit qu'il ya une adaptation à
la réalité
je m'en félicite c'est une bonne
nouvelle néanmoins m
il faut maintenant regarder de plus près
la situation actuelle la france en tant
que pays payent beaucoup plus de
services à la dette que la grèce
si maintenant on devrait expliquer aux
électeurs français de payer encore plus
d'argent pour la grèce pour que cesse ce
pays la paix encore moins de services à
la dette ça serait difficile à expliquer
donc il faut rester en balance dans tous
ces questions dans toutes ces questions
et j'espère que l'eurozone le conseil
des ministres de l'eurozone peut y
arriver en consentement avec le ministre
des finances grec dans les premiers dans
les prochaines chose quand ils vont se
rencontrer
ça va se dérouler dans les jours qui
suivent vous êtes plutôt optimiste et on
n'a toujours pas voyez vous comme
toujours mais s'il y avait un compromis
se serait sur quoi une
art échelonnement de la dette puisqu'on
parle d'un compromis la grèce devra
d'ici financer les dernières dettes dans
l'an 2000 57
c'est déjà assez loin si c'est
maintenant 58 ou 59 ça va pas changer
youri tc de nouvelles réformes par
exemple un plan m contre la cour la base
je trouve la barre des 20 ans de la
grèce la base madame devra être ce qu on
a discuté avec les anciens gouvernements
et si le nouveau gouvernement veut
améliorer sein en grèce d'accord et
l'europe veut et dit à la grèce mais on
peut pas dire on ne peut pas expliquer à
un électeur en france à un électeur en
espagne que celui là doit maintenant
encore payer plus pour la grèce bien que
ces pays ont déjà contribué largement à
aider la grèce
en clair si alexis tsipras se refuse
demain de continuer à travailler avec la
troïka
l'europe est fondé à dire et bien dans
ce cas on ne lui donne pas l'argent
non mais c'est moi je pense vous avez
déjà mentionné le fait que monsieur
tsipras ça aussi changer un peu de
langage
je pense à certain nombre de facteurs
ont été ont été changés dans les
dernières jours et pour cette raison je
peux et je pense au moins moi même je
pense qu'on peut arriver dans une
situation où le peuple grec peut voir à
nouveau que l'europe veut aider à la
grèce nous avons le plus grand d'intérêt
que la grèce reste en europe
nous avons le plus grand intérêt que ça
se fait comme prévu mais on peut pas
changer les règles et sans dans le jeu
et comme toujours en europe ce sera le
compromis qui va se décider
merci beaucoup entre choix pour votre
commentaire sur cette actualité
européenne chargée puisqu'il se passe
aussi des choses en espagne elle le
mouvement podemos monte dans les
sondages une mars a rassemblé plus de
cent mille personnes à madrid nous avons
pris le pouls de la manifestation
essayez de comprendre pourquoi beaucoup
de gens se tourner vers podemos et un
reportage signé est la mondah gava
caroline motte et véronique lorelle fini
la veille de la grande marche de madrid
les militants de podemos active pour
certains c'est la première fois qu'ils
s'impliquent autant dans un parti
politique
margarita 61 ans elle est professeur
tant d'autres qui pose est parti dans un
silo qui est né sont pas ces ados qui
aujourd'hui tous les partis politiques
ont eu des histoires
ils nous ont rendus méfiants nous avons
besoin d'un gouvernement d' espoir
il n'y a pas d'autres partis qui met
convaincu podemos c'est l'espoir d'un
futur meilleur
terence podemos et un nouveau parti
fondé il ya un nom en réaction à la
crise économique que traverse l'espagne
depuis plusieurs années en réel à 56 ans
il est au chômage depuis quatre ans et
vit avec 420 euros par mois alors que
son loyer s'élève déjà à 500 euros
il doit compter sur l'aide de ses
proches et doit faire des sacrifices
dior je n'ai pas de quoi payer le
chauffage je ne la lui mme pas alors
qu'à madrid ces derniers temps il a fait
moins 2 degrés à moi comme il en veut à
l'union européenne et au gouvernement
espagnol qui s'est laissé imposer un
plan d'austérité drastique
c'est une chose d' appartenir à l'union
européenne de donner et de recevoir
c'en est une autre d'arriver à une telle
humiliation ne pas pouvoir manger ne pas
pouvoir se chauffer quand il fait froid
ici il nous expulse à 7 heures du matin
quand on peut pas payer le loyer
même quand on a des petits enfants les
gens dorment dans les parcs
on est humilié des milliers lui à une
meilleure situation pourtant il a fait
400 km pour être présent à la marche du
changement médecin de famille son
salaire a baissé de 15% en quelques
années mais il a surtout vu l'état de la
population se dégrader
je le vois dans mon quotidien avec mes
patients par exemple ils sont de plus en
plus pauvres beaucoup n'ont pas de
travail et c'est difficile pour eux de
sortir juste un euro pour des
médicaments alors ils se soignent mal et
ne guérissent pas bien pour la première
fois il se rend à une réunion publique
de podemos et je préfère essayer quitte
à me tromper
si je me trompe en votant pour le parti
socialiste ou la droite là je m'en
voudrais vraiment parce que je serai
complices de leurs politiques
et ça je ne peux pas me le permettre
le mouvement invite ses sympathisants à
se regrouper en cercles de discussion
pour s'exprimer échanger
mais avant tout faire remonter à la tête
du parti des propositions concrètes des
cercles à madrid il y en a des dizaines
arthur y participent régulièrement même
si les français il ya des français des
italiens des allemands
on peut voter aux municipales mais pas
donc aux autres élections
mais c'est pas ça qui pose problème
on vient ici c'est moi et on sait qu'on
peut tout de suite participé du quartier
venaient à notre avis faire des projets
voilà c'est qu intéressant et aussi donc
il ya plusieurs français et l'idée c'est
aussi un peu d'essayer de voir ce qu'on
pourrait faire en france on pourrait
essayer de développer un peu ce modèle
comment faire les les autres ils étaient
au moins cent mille a défilé à madrid
pour la marche du 31 janvier pour les
manifestants c'était l'occasion
d'exprimer un ras-le-bol et une volonté
de changement pour le parti podemos une
manière de lancer la campagne pour les
élections de mai prochain la formation
politique est en tête des sondages
nous pouvons rêver nous avons gagné deux
invités nous ont rejoints sur ce plateau
pour discuter de ce phénomène podemos
deux invités espagnol avec nous
véronique a loupé fontanier bonjour
bonjour est députée européenne membre du
ppe qui regroupe les partis de droite et
de centre droit est à vos côtés inès
ayala sender bonjour je vous êtes
également des buts espagnols membres du
groupe des socialistes et démocrates on
va pas faire de débat de politique
intérieure espagnole on n'ose f et de
comprendre ce phénomène podemos comment
expliquez-vous ce succès de ce mouvement
qui a à peine un an
bon je crois que on le voit un peu dans
le reportage et le mécontentement la
crise économique les mesures que le
gouvernement a été obligé de prendre
pour sortir de la prison est en train
petit à petit de améliorer la situation
il ya la croissance en espagne mais
évidemment la situation était difficile
et il y a une la population était très
mécontente des mesures qui ont été pris
mais je crois que ça a été nécessaire et
on n'a pas d'autres moyens en ce moment
est-ce que vous avez la même analyse que
votre moi je pense que vraiment
on a eu une citation ou au niveau
européen on a on n'a pas su donner une
réponse pas seulement au genou convoi
dans le doubs à la personne personnes
âgées qui ont perdu leur boulot mais
notamment en général à la croissance et
au développement de l'emploi en europe
oui c'est sa sonde européenne qui est
directement responsable de la montée de
dollars istanbul a oui parce que ils
vont dire on a imposé et d'une façon on
le voit très clair dans la brèche
nord-sud qui s'est ouverte et comment
les pays du sud ont été contraints à des
mesures d'aidé des mesures structurelles
visant imposé par la tri car et par
notamment par le gouvernement de droite
allemande qui ont mis
les gens dans une situation impossible
mais on ajoute à ça que les
gouvernements comme disait ma collègue
le gouvernement de droite en espagne à
aider encore avec des mesures
supplémentaires par exemple via des
privatisations d'hôpitaux de
privatisation de l'éducation et ça
encore appauvri en plus les espagnols le
leader iglesias dit c'est la faute des
deux partis dominants en espagne qu'est
ce que vous lui répondez qui n'ont par
exemple de dinars est en soi sens et ce
n'est pas la faute de l'europe s'il ya
une crise économique les pays
beaucoup ont vécu dans l'espagne avait
vécu en deux ans dessus de leurs moyens
et un moment il faut payer les dettes et
il faut faire les restrictions
nécessaires pour continuer pour ne pas
être en faillite et je crois que on a
fait ce qu'on a dû faire et je crois
qu'en ce moment il ya cinq ans il ya six
ans l'espagne était le parti quitte le
pays qui crée le plus de problèmes à
l'europe et en ce moment on voit la
croissance on voit que les audiences il
ya eu il ya eu une réussite
qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec podemos
c'est évident que il ya des
mécontentements avec raison et c'est
facile un payet parti ou des personnes
qui disent qu'ils vont tout arranger
qu'on va pas payer la dette qu'on va
augmenter les salaires on va moins
travailler on va pas payer d'impôts les
gens sont contents mais il faut
réellement savoir quelle est la réalité
et
ça c'est pas la réalité il faut pas
mentir aux électeurs est-ce que vous
pensez que ce programme est réaliste
nommez moi et recommencer je suis pas
d'accord qu'on a vécu en dessus de la
capacité puisqu'en 2007 l'espagne
n'avait presque pas de déficit public
avait pas de dettes publiques la dette
était énormément privé parce que tant
les entreprises comme les foyers étaient
comme on dit repoussé par les banques et
là je voudrais dire deux noms qui ne
sont pas seulement des banques
espagnoles mais aussi des banques par
exemple la fois allemand mais si on a
aidé les banques on a on est absolument
pousser les gens mais que vous pouvez
pas imaginer à prendre des hypothèques
sur des pas seulement sur pour payer
leur leur appartement pour vivre mais
aussi le meubler le web de la voiture
c'est ça a été vraiment une pour une
course à l'endettement privé et quand la
crise est venue évidemment les banques
et ça a été une décision prise à niveau
européen et pas seulement au niveau
espagnol
pas du tout les resserrer de mètres de
cette situation absolument par la
politique d'austérité et par la
politique de m en avance les problèmes
des banques qui étaient qui avait
endetté la population et les entreprises
du coup il voulait voilà avoir l'air
bil'in nickel mais ça a été tout d'un
coup on a racheté la dette privée s'est
convertie par imposition de l'europe en
dette publique et du coup voilà on était
dans une situation impossible comme
comme pays et on a vu la dell à la prime
de risque monte monte aussi vous savez
que la prime de risque à une un bilan
avec le
comment dire là la monnaie l'euro mais
aussi les la bundesbank de façon que j
ai vraiment une position qui est dans
l'europe a été responsable de ne pas
immédiatement comme ça a été aux états
unis on l'a vu très clairement de
pousser pour la croissance et pour
l'investissement rapidement comme c'est
le cas quand il ya une crise de tels les
etats-unis sont sortis déjà là on serait
encore dans l'exigence vous allez
répondre à votre collègue est ce que le
gouvernement espagnol aurait pu faire un
peu plus pour ceux qui n'on qui n'ont
pas grand chose aujourd'hui
le gouvernement espagnol est en train et
a fait beaucoup de choses quand on
apprit le gouvernement je voulais pas
rentrer dans une discussion de politique
intérieure mais ma collègue même obligé
par l'europe quand on commence à trouver
un pays qui est pratiquement en faillite
il faut pas vous passer que nous on
était des pays qu'on voulait intervenir
le parce que là que la situation était
difficile
maintenant c'est ça s'est amélioré on a
fait des réformes très importantes
on est en train de créer les impôts des
emplois on n'a pas besoin descendu les
pensions des
des personnes dès qu'ils étaient à la
retraite on a fait tout ce qu'on a pu et
la réussite je crois va se voir dans le
temps dans le torrent bientôt alors on
attend dans le tableau de lysias excusez
moi je voudrais dire aussi l'europe
n'est pas coupable
personne ne vous empêche de gestion' et
bien les choses
et évidemment c'est ce que dit marine le
pen c'est ce que disent tous les partis
anti-européens le bouquet lauréats fait
de le regarder
pas du tout alors j'ai une décision
d'une europe d'une europe où une
majorité ont décidé d'opter par là par
l'austérité et nous sommes partis c'est
pour ça qu'on est en train de sortir de
la crise bon là mais justement il ya la
moitié disent les experts
en tout cas il ya peu il ya en tout cas
la montée de ces partis syriza en grèce
podemos en espagne pablo iglesias lui
croit en sa bonne étoile élu député
européen ici en mai dernier il a
maintenant un programme pour son
mouvement résumé comme cela écouter
le vent du changement commence à
souffler en europe au moins d'une
semaine voilà ce qu'a fait le
gouvernement grec électricité gratuite
pour trois cent mille familles qui ne
pouvait plus payer arrêt des
privatisations des ports de la compagnie
générale d'électricité et de 14hà
airoport couverture sociale pour tous
les citoyens reconnaissance de la
nationalité grecque pour tous les
enfants peu importe la couleur de leurs
cours réadmission des professeurs is
happy end à piger a dit que nous ne
pouvions rien faire qui a dit qu'un
gouvernement ne pouvait pas changer les
choses alors votre réaction sur toutes
ces mesures là est-ce que c'est
totalement utopique ou est-ce que ça
peut être mis en place
nous c'est pas en principe ce sont des
mesures à long terme de la grèce
mais il parle pas et ça c'est la grande
question sur le programme en relation
avec l'europe ou silice a dit déjà il
veut pas s'asseoir et l'espagne la grèce
est ce que pour vous on peut comparer
les deux pays l'espagne n'est pas la
grèce ça c'est clair ni par les passer
parce que la situation fiscale de la
grèce n'a rien à voir avec la la
capacité la situation fiscale en espagne
puisque on a comme on dire c'était le
gouvernement service
au commencement des années 80 qui a
organisé le système fiscal and en
espagne et
voilà c'est d'avoir la capacité des
commandes hier les jeunes les jeunes qui
sont préparés et toutes les institutions
qui s'organise
malgré des situations difficiles mais là
c'est que je trouve que c'est la
question est là on est dans le parlement
européen
c'est quelle est la position du podemos
par rapport à la haute comment dire à la
position de l'espagne en europe la
inzaghi il n'a pas dit ça il a changé
très vive et ma vie par rapport à la
dette a commandé à sortir ou pas de
l'euro et c est ce que c'est un danger
c'est ce sont là des mots quand vous
parlez vous dit
le programme de peau des mains alors sur
un programme ça ce sont des promesses
mais il faudrait savoir avec quoi ils
vont payer
qu'est ce qui s'est passé en grèce avec
quoi vous payer la grèce on le savait
les dettes qu'ils ont avec les français
avec les espagnols avec les allemands on
va devoir donner plus d'argent ils vont
pas rendre l'argent demandé aussi les
armagnacais ce qu'il pense en espagne on
calcule que déjà l'argent qu'on a prêté
6 à peu près 600 euros par personne
on peut faire des promesses comme ça
mais il faut payer les dettes aussi
c'est long ça pour vous comme comme idée
c'est pas non mais ça c'est la jolie de
dire tout le monde va tout le monde est
gentil et tout le monde va aider tout le
monde évidemment tous les partis on veut
aider tout le monde
mais après il faut payer et la peau des
manches ne parle pas du tout 2 comment
il va faire comment quel est le budget
d'où il va sortir l'argent et ça on n'en
parle pas du tout c'est pas un programme
électoral et d'ailleurs je crois que il
sait qu'il ne pourrait pas le faire et
j'espère qu'il ne gouvernera pas parce
qu'une si on est en tort sortir de la
crise ce serait pour l'espagne la
catastrophe parce qu'à ce moment là on
serait à nouveau au ban de l'europe au
demos au pouvoir une catastrophe pour
l'espagne et pour l'europe
bon en tout cas nous on est pour la
démocratie de façon que de la même façon
qu'on a accepté la situation en grèce et
une appuyée
résultat 100 m voilà c'est aux espagnols
le moment venu de dire mais c'est vrai
que dans les élections un danger pour la
longue ça veut dire ce qu'il en appelle
directement au peuple cette forme de
démocratie directe est ce que ça vaut
mais c'est yvon les espagnols vont voter
ils ont les droits à voter come back en
partie vrai dire on peut dire le même du
front national en france et ils vont ils
vont participer dans l'est dans les
élections mais non je veux dire que
c'est plutôt la façon de de se présenter
aux élections par exemple
en mai nous avons des gens les élections
locales et régionales est là pour des
mon style
il n'a pas voulu se présenter pour ne
pas tacher en disant avec la gestion au
quotidien du municipal local qui est la
base de la gestion politique
ils ont dit ah non nous ne voulons pas
entrer dans ces élections on attend
l'écran élections où c'est comment dire
plus facile de faire seulement des
promesses accord est pas mettre vraiment
jouer avec les besoins des gens et ne
pas mettre un programme où vraiment on
s'oblige les quotidiens du local et du
régional est beaucoup plus dure et c'est
sympa pour moi c'est la grande question
pourquoi ils veulent pas se mettre
or comment dire en égalité des chances
avec les restes de partie pour se
présenter aux élections locales avec
leur logo étiquette
on verra bien jusqu'où marcheront les
militants de podemos merci à vous on
essaye à la thunder et avoue véronique
et à l'opé frontaliers d'avoir été sur
ce plateau pour d'autres données cet
éclairage vue d'espagne très bonne suite
de programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
on se donne rendez vous la semaine
prochaine ce sera nora ahmadi bye bye
voilà